la sphère ford et régler les voitures de
l'écurie shelby seront demain au départ
rappelons que l'accident des essais
provoqua de bodega vous pouvez ici le
constater mais le pilote est indemne
un bon conseil soyez plus prudent demain
sur les routes de la sarthe
passons dans les stands
ici nous sommes environ à 280 84,5
même le bien un double dip
si nous prenons
photo ap deux rouges à 300 m
elle s'en remettre
2e
premier virage de termonde bien là la
corde à gauche
à condition que ce second virage
pour cent
150 à l'heure
lalonde virage annuel 100 m ici toujours
toi 13 à l'extérieur période où ils
accordent et la corde
tous les jours
elle d'achat si on paye droite et hino
nous savions
leur espace et
oui
ailleurs des écoles
exactement 300 m
200 m 2e
50 m
premières images jamison
est ce que vous touchez les pattie
malette en cuir âge
très près de moi ne pas disons
prendre cm parce que
bien problème il ya beaucoup de sable et
si on met une roue dans le salon sans
plus
dia la police deuxième à la corde
on l'a senti rentrent à l'heure
le deuxième freinage à la corde à gauche
que j'accorde à gauche
après des phases i
le 100 m pour arnage 1h des virages de
plus de mystère c'est non sept virages
veut plus lent du circuit on et nous
nous prenons environ soixante dix à
l'heure
maxime
troisième
la police paul hanna virage près de la
division
oui pour entrer à l'intérieur ici
la ligne droite